حيواناتٌ حيواناتْ بين الناس وفي الغاباتْ
تعطي جمالا للحياةْ يالَ جمالِ الكائناتْ
بِصَيَاحِي دَوْمًا صَدَّاحْ *** أُوقِظُكُمْ فِي كُلِّ صَبَاحْ
لِي هَيْبَتِي بَيْنَ الطُّيُورْ *** أَنَا الدِّيكُ المَحْبُوبُ يَا صَاحْ
لِلْبَشَرِ أَنَا أَغْلَى صَدِيقْ *** لِي صَوْتٌ وَيُسَمَّى نَهِيقْ
مَشْهُورٌ أًدْعَى الحِمَارْ ***   لِلْجُهْدِ وَلِلتَّعَبِ أُطِيقْ
هُنَا وَهُنَاكَ أَنُطُّ وَأَلْعَبْ *** طُولَ نَهَارِي أَنَا لَا أَتْعَبْ
أُنْظُرُوا مَا أَحْلَى أُذُنَيْ *** مَحْبُوبٌ وَأُسَمَّى الْأَرْنَبْ
حيواناتٌ حيواناتْ بين الناس وفي الغاباتْ
تعطي جمالا للحياةْ يالَ جمالِ الكائناتْ
أَنَا المِعْزَةْ قَدْ جِئْتُ الْآَنْ *** تُمَيِّزُنِي عِدَّةُ أَلْوَانْ
فَقَوَامِي رَشِيقٌ وَقَوِيْ *** وَأُعْطِيكُمْ أَشْهَى الْأَلْبَانْ
وَأَنَا سَفِينَةُ الصَّحْرَاءْ *** هُنَاكَ أَعِيشُ بِدُونِ عَنَاءْ
جَمَلٌ وَيُمَيِّزُنِي سَنَامِي *** وَأَيْضًا بِالصَّبْرِ عَنِ المَاءْ
لِي مِنْقَارٌ أَعْرَضُ أَطْوَلْ *** طَيِّبَةُ القَلْبِ أَنَا الْأَجْمَلْ
أَنَا بَطَّةْ أَسْبَحُ فِي البِرْكَةْ *** وَبِهَا أَقْضِي وَقْتًا أَفْضَلْ
حيواناتٌ حيواناتْ بين الناس وفي الغاباتْ
تعطي جمالا للحياةْ يالَ جمالِ الكائناتْ